et sachez que les personnels des ehpad
korian sont appelés à la grève
aujourd'hui cela concerne plus de 50
établissements du groupe qui gère
environ 5% des maisons de retraite en
france
l'intersyndicale réclame des mesures
fortes de la part du gouvernement
on peut citer par exemple
l'élargissement de la prime de 1500
euros pour tout le personnel une
augmentation de salaires de 300 euros
net par mois ou encore la reconnaissance
vieux corona bien russe en maladie
professionnelle et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct avec albert papadacci
délégué central cgt
korian bonjour monsieur papadacci merci
et des troncs direct avec nous sur rt
france alors ce ne sont pas tous les
établissements du groupe qui sont en
grève ça veut dire quoi que la crise
sanitaire est gérée différemment selon
les établissements
non pas du tout ça dépend où les
salariés sont les salariés sont motivés
on a pratiquement à ce matin plus de 60
établissements qui ont fait une confié
une action ce soit un débrayage que ce
soit une grève en nous on estime que c
est ce que c'est un gros succès il ya
aussi des établissements qui n'ont pas
souffert énormément de la pandémie mais
en majorité les salariés se plaignent
aujourd'hui de cette pandémie de cette
problématique
alors qui vous visent et a concrètement
la direction les états où le
gouvernement à écouter les deux la
direction nous on estime comme il est
titulaire dans le reportage que vous
avez présenté que le gouvernement a
failli à sa mission
nous nous estimons que notre entreprise
a failli à sa mission on s'est retourné
sur les préconisations ministériel alors
qu'il me semble qu'une entreprise de ce
tas caby aussi grosse que korian ne
pouvait prendre les démesures avant il
ya eu des des contre vérités il ya eu
des mensonges quand on nous a annoncé
que tout le matériel était arrivé au 28
février au 3 mars
on a eu tout le matériel entre le 24 et
le 27 mars
malgré les annonces qui ont été faites
dans la presse à la télévision vendredi
après générale en disant que tout avait
dit vrai le 20 mars
non c'est pas vrai d'ailleurs à ce sujet
là dans les différences et à ceux où
nous sommes ou la cgt représentait nous
posons des questions sur les séances du
mois de mai
voulons avoir la preuve des commandes de
masques nous voulons avoir les bons de
livraison
nous voulons avoir les d état de stocks
du mois de février du mois de mars et du
mois d'avril
les salariés ont été mises en danger ça
nous le dénonçons bien sûr eos moment
quelle est la situation sur place dans
les ehpad du groupe korian alors il est
évident que la pandémie commence à abc
mais il n'empêche que les salariés sont
fatigués des salariés sont en colère il
n'y a toujours pas de reconnaissance les
congés ont été reportés les
récupérations ont été reportés les
salariés ont fait beaucoup d'heures
supplémentaires elles sont fatiguées
elles sont en colère et on attend
toujours la reconnaissance on ne parle
de primes depuis deux mois d'avril on
nous parle d'une prime
le ministre a aussi parlé d'une prime et
on ne voit on ne voit pas le jour le
seul jours qu'on voit c'est travaille
plus on travaille plus on travaille plus
à un moment donné c'est pas possible
justement en parlant de prime vous
réclamez cette prime de 1500 euros
qu'elles soient octroyés finalement à
tout le monde parce que vous dénoncez un
peu l'opposition public privé où
l'opposition selon l'endroit dans lequel
les salariés travaillent non nous on
dénonce rien nous on est bien content
que le que les salariés que les agents
du public puisse avoir de la
reconnaissance du travail effectué et
des augmentations de salaire et des
primes et nous rendait dans ce parent
n'est pas jaloux du tout sauf que notre
direction générale nous annonce que la
prime l'expriment dit mc ren hauteur de
1000 euros sera versée à l'ensemble des
salariés et le mist d'un côté il dit
qu'il ya eu plus de 1500 euros qui sera
versée président pas dans l'ensemble des
salariés pour moi on n'a rien vu du tout
on sait que ces primes là peut-être
peut-être vont être déversées mais avec
des critères d'attribution
ce qui veut bien dire un critère ça veut
dire on va voir à qui on va le donner et
si on peut donner le moins possible à
moins de monde possible
c'est encore mieux ça coûtera moins
d'argent c'est ça c'est ça le problème
sans ces critères nous que nous
dénonçons c'est pour ça qu'à la cgt nous
venons d'énoncer des primes sous laon
sont de véritables mutations de salaires
et la reconnaissance dans les conditions
de travail et dans les salaires les
primes c'est bien mais il ya tellement
de critères dans les dents les primes
que finalement il ya une 50% sont % des
salariés qui vont l'apercevoir et
peut-être pas la totalité
c'est ça le scandale alors finalement on
a un peu la pression que la crise
sanitaire actuelle que la crise du
coronavirus a mis en lumière
à l'aise déjà existants dans les ehpad
alors ils savaient déjà été mis en
lumière fin 2018 avec ses grosses
journées de manifestations et de
mobilisation qui a eu sur l'ensemble de
la france dans les ehpad et privés et
publics
il s'avère que depuis maintenant deux
ans ans n'a pas l'intention ni que le
gouvernement nie que nos entreprises ont
compris le message donc effectivement il
faut redescendre dans la rue il faut
montrer qu'on n'est pas contents que
pour arriver à transformer de fond en
comble le système il faut savoir quand
même que ces ehpad privés sont financées
par les ars pour les salaires et par et
conseils départementaux pour les soins à
hauteur de 50 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires
alors donc ses cent des fonds publics
qui financent ces groupes privés
lucratifs mais par contre ce sont les
groupes privés lucratifs qui gardent les
dividendes et qui gardent les bénéfices
en redistribue pas à ce moment là ni aux
salariés ni à l'état alors votre grève
un coin c'est de bien évidemment avec le
grand ségur de la santé qui va commencer
à 15h30
et qu'est ce que vous en attendez de
cette grande concertation moi
personnellement et insultés on n'attend
pas grand-chose servetto quoi encore des
effets d'annoncé qui vont être faits en
disant on va augmenter les salaires
depuis des années il ya une
déstructuration du service public une
déstructuration de l'hôpital public
hélas uniquement monsieur mac on aurait
compris que toutes ces politiques
capitalistes depuis des années c'est pas
bien et qu'il faut réalimenter hôpital
qu'il faut créer des postes qu'il faut
augmenter d augmenter les salaires il a
compris ça maintenant
moi je n'y crois pas une seule seconde
tout est fait pour détruire le service
public
tout est fait pour des pour détruire
notre prestation sociale nous ce qu'on
réclame c'est un grand service public de
santé
le privé lucratif ne doit pas s'occuper
de la santé c'est c'est du domaine
public la santé dont je n'attends pas
grand chose de ces figures de ce secteur
de la santé en plus ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas une négociation c'est l'état
qui va annoncer qui va annoncer ce qu'il
compte mettre en place mais elle est où
la négociation avec des partenaires
sociaux monsieur papadacci merci d'avoir
été en direct avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes délégué sens
tu râles cgt du groupe korian merci
c'est ça je vous remercie au revoir